this game is for you the fan you want
the action to flow the bat on the ball
and carrying on the base paths this is
the game we all want to see
yeah it sure is after Brian Cranston is
excited for the changes to Major League
Baseball welcome back to CBS morning's
put me in coach tomorrow's opening day
for the league all 30 teams returning to
action and as Cranston just mentioned
fans May notice some big changes in how
the game is played I'm going to give you
a little run through first up the pitch
clock here's how it's going to work
pitchers will have 15 seconds to set and
deliver 20 seconds when a runner is on
base and batters they must be ready to
hit by the time that clock reaches 8
Seconds
second goodbye infield shift good
riddance that means two players much
must be on either side of the bag in the
infield you can no longer move your
infielders to the Outfield or the other
side of the infield to try to take away
hits and finally the bases themselves
are actually getting a little bit bigger
three inches on either side to be exact
and those changes all together have one
goal in mind to add more action to the
game more hits more stolen bases and
speeding up the pace of play and they
come as Major League Baseball celebrates
record-setting Revenue last year and we
are joined by the commissioner Rob
Manfred to talk about all this thank you
very much for being here commissioner
glad to be here uh this is an exciting
day for me I don't know about my
colleagues over here we have to get them
on the baseball train what you talking
about you talking about these changes
I've seen them in pre-season play uh I
think they're fantastic I think they
make the game quick and athletic the way
I remember it being in the 80s and 90s
watching it on TV jumping around on my
couch at home what was the impetus for
you guys when did you finally say we got
to do this I don't care who's opposed
well this was kind of a long-term
project but it began with fan research
we noticed the game was changing on the
field we went to our fans we solicited
their views and it was a very clear
indication from fans that they wanted a
game with more action better Pace
less Reliance on strikeouts and home
runs and maybe most important focusing
on the athleticism of our great players
got unbelievable middle infielders in
baseball they can do incredible things
but you've got the big data crunching
telling everyone where to stand and
instead of letting a guy play they just
go stand on the spot and hold their
glove up and then the other thing that
seems to have happened is pitchers are
throwing so hard which is amazing to
watch but when they have unlimited time
to walk around and reload the cannon
right no one hits it and it's boring we
think that changes work together in
order to promote getting the ball in
play giving fans more action less
downtime in the game and overall overall
producing a game that looks like the
game that most of us grew up with we
don't think we're changing the game we
think we're restoring yeah Ricky
Henderson Ozzie Smith those those
players of the 80s and 90s I want that
game back what's the reaction from the
players number one good on you for
listening to fans who who said something
because a lot of people think
well you can feel the way you feel but
this is what we're going to do so good
on you for listening what are the
players saying to you about our players
have been amazingly positive about the
changes did that surprise you it did it
did I think change is difficult for
players you know they've reached a
pinnacle you know it's so hard to become
a major league player any change causes
uncertainty is it going to affect my
performance I think they as they've
gotten used to the rules
um they like the fact that the game
moves along better that there's more
action
um and you know we've tried to be
receptive to their input and have made
adjustments around the edges
um to to deal with things that frankly
only players would understand yeah Rob I
want to get your thoughts on the
diversity in the game there was report
in the early 90s that black or
African-American players made up around
18 last year that was all the way down
to seven and it seems like that number
is starting to get lower and lower what
do you believe is the main issue here
when you have black athletes that could
be one hell of a baseball player
choosing to go play other sports
sometimes a sport like football that you
might not last as long and you might
face more criticism that might not make
as much money but they're walking away
from a beautiful sport like baseball
well our Focus has really been on
providing playing opportunities in
places where they often were not
available we've invested heavily in
youth programming and playing
opportunities in underserved areas and
frankly it's one of the best Returns on
investment anywhere in our business last
year for example for the first time ever
four out of our first try five draft
picks were African-American and every
single one of those draft picks came out
of one of the programs that we're
running around country so it is a place
where you can make a difference if you
put some money into providing people
with opportunities baseball's got a Hall
of Famer named Pete Rose who is not a
Hall of Famer because he gambled on his
his own team and now legalized Sports
gambling has taken over uh Pro Sports
how how is it changing the game good
question to read it's a good question
well I think that
um it's important that
um all of our rules are designed to make
sure that sports betting doesn't change
the game of baseball that it can't have
any effect on the play of the game on
the field and there are special rules
that apply to players employees field
Managers from a business perspective
there is a business there we have a
large Data Business that is significant
it's also significant in terms of
sponsorship and and other lines of our
business yeah when Tony started he was
saying you know about Nate and I I have
sometimes thought it's a little dry a
little long this is the new Improvement
but but I've actually been to games I've
actually been to games and when you go
to the park the in the infield
experience is really really nice I love
the food I love the camaraderie it
really is a good experience I will say
that Marcus strowman was here and he
said people that say baseball is boring
I look at them like they've lost their
minds baseball is fascinating if you
know the game you know know that there's
always something going on right you
clearly love this game too why I look I
think baseball
occupies a unique spot in our culture
there's something about the association
um that Americans have with our game
that's special and I do believe the game
has characteristics that are really
important
um to Americans there's certain values
embedded in it you have to stick to it
it's a very hard game it's a subtle game
teamwork and you know I grew up a fan
and probably a bigger fan today we have
a countdown clock ready just for you
commissioner okay 20 seconds on the
clock first thing that comes to your
mind your favorite Morning Show no no
favorite player of all time Mickey
Mantle oh favorite ballpark food hot dog
favorite baseball memory uh probably my
first game 1968 Yankees Stadium Mickey
Mantle hit two home oh that's a good one
oh that's great if you were an MLB
player do you play by the way I played
little league and was not very good Gail
what would your walk-up song be oh
Thunder Road that's easy
I'm Too Sexy From Thunderbird Bruce
Springsteen you could never go wrong and
if you have uh
answer this if you have a dinner party
what three baseball people would you
invite Dead or Alive
you know Mickey Mantle's easy
um I think commissioner Landis I think
he'd be an interesting character
um and it would have to be one of
today's players maybe Ken Griffey Jr oh
the kid very nice Rob he knocked it out
the park thank you thank you all right
thank you congrats congrats